our friends at manscapes are turning
their men's shower dreams into their
favorite routines the ultra premium new
collection is an all-in-one hygiene skin
and hair bundle
it's designed to upgrade your shower
from head to toe using manscape during
my showers after workout has given me
much more confidence the shower routine
uses all the collections products you
start with the cologne infused ultra
premium body wash you'll smell so great
all the ladies will be after you next
you apply the two in one shampoo and
conditioner that cleanses once you hop
out the shower apply the manscape
aluminum free deodorant if you have
tattoos or dry skin
hit your skin with a hydrating body
moisturizer spray last but not least
check out the lawn mower 4.0 electric
trimmer to clean off any unwanted body
hair the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof and so it can join you in the
shower
although your balls might look like
punching bags don't treat them like one
the lawn mower is designed to cut hair
on loose skin get 20 or free shipping
with code to hot boxing at
manscape.com that's 20 off free shipping
with code hotboxing at manscape.com
it's time to get wet and clean with your
new manscape shower routine so your
thoughts on jake paul my guy jake i like
jake yeah i like jake he's cool well
they were talking about him fighting you
or you fighting him or logan is that
something that still
[Laughter]
let me adam
[Music]
hey this is mike tyson another episode
of hot boxing and i have my man
sebastian over here and we have israel
edda sagna the one to know
the one and only style bender [ __ ] your
ass up
i'm a nice guy i'm chill i'm chill so
tell me brother this is awesome and
happy brother
how long you been champion so far how
long i've been championed well in the
ufc since
2019 early 2009 yeah um but i've always
felt this way like i've always felt this
way anyone who's watched my journey
i was just saying
kind of like ali he said this quote i'm
the greatest i said it before i knew i
was
from fight number four and kickboxing
i remember just feeling like
i could be really like the best at this
i didn't know how i hadn't cause okay
look i'm not athletic i'm big and black
i can't play basketball i'm nigerian
football's not my thing i'm from new
zealand i don't play rugby you know like
i couldn't catch a ball for [ __ ] they
called me butterfingers in high school
but somehow i was just like i'm good at
this fighting [ __ ] and i just felt like
jackie chan whenever i fought so i was
like i could be the best at this and the
conviction just stuck with me and yeah
here we are still with me
yeah that's crazy yeah it's a drug yeah
it's it's one of those things as well
like when i first started i remember my
first fight
the the feeling of it because i fought
this guy you know david tour right he's
a boston
legend this guy had a haircut like him
like the high high top fade and he was
definitely not in my weight class but
then when i fought him
the first like i stood in front of him
and this is my first ever fight amateur
fight and in my head i'm like
what are you doing this guy's going to
whip your ass holy [ __ ]
you can't fight holy [ __ ] he looks mean
he's going to kick your ass and i touch
gloves yeah let's go boom i touch let's
go to the corner
and then within the first 15 10 seconds
i remember i dropped them with a drop
kick and this feeling of confidence just
surged through me and i remember just
feeling like
just god mode but then after that
everything else was a blur
then after the fight everyone was like
man you did amazing [ __ ] you were this
you were that you were that and i was
just like really
okay i watched the fight back now i was
just [ __ ] i was like a [ __ ] bronco
i didn't know some people in the fight i
feel maybe not born to it but it's just
something in me something no no no no
some people are just born they'll fight
yeah they could be a little bookkeeper
there could be a lawyer and stuff until
that switch is turned on yeah that's it
the switch cause i don't remember the
fight at all and after the fight when i
watched the tape back i was like damn
damn that was me yeah it's like [ __ ]
even now whenever i look in my eyes when
i fight
it's uh it's like i know that guy i've
met him before but it's not me right now
this is me i'm sure you know this is
what even you notice when you go when
you go on the field you have to turn
that switch on when it's like yo
that's game time fox yeah you know how
many people that can't turn that switch
on and see if they can turn it on and
can't turn it off yeah that's the world
guys
now yeah i mean i've never been that guy
but i don't like to live in that mode
too much because it's not
it's not healthy not it's not healthy
like i don't know if you've ever i've
been there i've been there where it's
like i'm always looking for static in
this that's what i love there's two
things people say when they first meet
me like especially fans is like oh my
god you're a lot bigger in person
and man you're a lot different like
you're on tv i'm like bro you're not
trying to fight me it's different like
if you're trying to fight me then it's
it's [ __ ] ecstatic you know then it's
like i'll give you that energy but
nah i'm just i'm just me i like to have
you you are taller [ __ ] though that [ __ ]
threw me off
oh my god damn yeah this guy
i know what it is about the tv though
and things i'm taller than a lot of my
opponents but the tv somehow either
shrinks me or it's because i'm cutting
weight i look i look shredded and skinny
but
no i get around i'm like bigfoot yeah
yeah well
so your next fight mm-hmm with jared
jared kind of near let's talk about that
let's look at this cat he's on i set him
up before let me see uh before he fought
whitaker uh in in abu dhabi and he
failed that one i felt like he still
he's he's the dark horse of the division
he's the guy that everyone sleeps on
yeah and yeah he he's a [ __ ] a
good knight he could beat anything he's
a beast exactly anyone can be anyone on
any night yeah that's one thing you can
never take for granted in this game in
the fight game yeah all it takes is even
oh bro i was watching this fight what
was the one um i can't remember the
guy's name but we're watching this fight
on the ocoee undercard this dude was
getting his ass whooped in the corner i
know if you know laurence coley he's a
boxer from from the uk he was getting
his ass warped in the corner just
blocking blocking blocking for about
three rounds cause he got there late and
then it was i think the tenth round in
the last second and he knocks the guy
out crazy
knocks the guy out flatlines him and
then the whole place just blows up so
yeah all you need is one second
no yeah a second of fighting is too slow
um tenth of a second yeah you're right
you imagine that second crazy slow for
fighting it's crazy
yeah well this is when he was in light
heavy weight heavy weight he was here so
he's coming from heavyweight dropped out
of the way
the black guy the black guy jared yeah
he's coming down to middleweight to
fight you now he's been that
middleweight for a while now but he
started off i remember this is
heavyweight
look at him kevin you can see he's a
little bit chunky
just a little bit but even then he went
down the light heavyweight and then
brought even back down the middleweight
but i feel like this is where he belongs
in middleweight but yeah yeah
i told him fight though right yeah that
was a heavyweight fight can we feel him
in the middleweight this is him at let
me see
yeah he does look like he does like
shredded here yeah yeah little trimmer
get a little more trimmer so this isn't
my light heavyweight and then you'll see
him later on the middle way he looks
shredded he looks like he belongs that
middleweight he's good he's good
unfortunately ain't not good enough but
he's not gonna know why he's not good
enough because he telegraphs everything
he does mm-hmm
i'm telling the secrets
i'm telling him secrets man this is him
yeah he is he's faster he's faster at
this way he's not telegraphing as much
that's crazy he dropped that much weight
though [ __ ] well a lot of people you'd
be surprised especially at the highest
level that's because he wants to fight
you bad huh no i told him so he fought
on my undercard my last fight two weeks
ago and i said to him i was like bro
take this cause he's for he fought a guy
brunson who i already beat at msg and i
said to him at the end i was like man
just take care of this guy so i can get
some fresh meat because i've already
like beat brunson i've beat victoria
i've beat um robert all these guys so i
don't want i don't want to laugh i'm
laughing at the difference in the back
but i want some fresh some fresh blood
yeah some people i haven't fought yet
this is him fighting silva you know
yeah yeah yeah he took him out with a
leg kick if i recall so i remember this
guy was invincible at one time yeah man
now silver was the one wasn't it yeah he
was invincible yeah yeah i think just he
was ahead of everybody else and i fought
him and
yeah that was a fun fight that was some
movie type [ __ ]
and he's still good man that's the thing
on any given day he can still follow
people up but he's just father time
catches up with you
oh
but while you have i mean while you have
it while you have your youth i feel like
you know maximizing you got it bro
maximizing right now i love it he's
hungry this guy yes thank you and you're
watching this is against her mansion
who's another paradigm guy
but yeah he took care of him pretty good
and that was just before me and robert
fought that's us on the on on the cage
again did he ever fight robert he fought
he fought robert robert beat him he beat
him right now yeah but um yeah his last
fight he knocked out brunson and i'm a
man of my word i was like you beat him
and you got the next shot so yeah we'll
try and take care of him um where's tim
maybe midway next year or this year yeah
because he's coming at you with
everything of course yeah i know this is
his chance
like when you're on top when you're on
top everyone wants
to talk everyone sees it so i know
whenever i fight anyone that's like for
me i don't see myself as the champ i
don't i don't even know where my belt is
right now mm-hmm i'm sure it's with
eugene somewhere in some box gathering
up dust but i never there's a clip of
you with that guy going this is garbage
this is garbage like that i don't feel
like that yet
but i never feel like i'm you know like
some guys like kobe it was the time when
he had the belt
he'd walk around everywhere with it yeah
i would do the same everywhere i've done
it before
i'm going to pull my hand
chilling don't get me wrong i had a car
with my belt on yeah all my life since i
was 11 years old that's what i dreamed
about yeah i think i killed so many
things about me walking around with it
yeah
you got to flex on them like i love that
kind of stuff so i've done that but then
there's a point where i realized that i
had epiphany like i don't want to get
attached to this i don't want this to be
my identity is all i am so i was just
like that's fine i'll walk around with
like when i get back home
this way it gets tricky you're not
attached to it it's attached to you
it is without even being on me yeah
that's cause the target on the back they
all want it they all want what that
thing represents i like the way you put
that what it represents so for me even
when i go back home to new zealand i'll
have to do some media stuff
i'll have to hold it be around with it
it'll be at my house for a little bit
but then when camp starts
then i give it back to eugene i'm just
like right i don't want this anymore so
then i just i don't look at it i don't
touch it nothing so that way i just get
to focus and i feel like
i'm just fighting bro all i want to do
is just fight and take away
all the top guys in my division
right now so when it's all said and done
they can be like look he never shied
away from anyone yeah and you can never
sell
anyone you can ask i never turn down any
fight any fighter anyone that's that
wanted it they they can get it you love
this [ __ ] huh i don't i know i'm the
[ __ ] but i know i ain't [ __ ] that's like
i know i'm the [ __ ] i'll never shy away
from that but i know i ain't [ __ ]
because yeah i mean i get humbled in the
gym every other day yeah you know i've
got killers in my gym you know so i i
know where i'm at and i know what i need
to work on so
yeah it's just that balance facts i know
exactly
when i was the fight i was champ
um i want to pick your brave you didn't
kill at all if you didn't kick my ass i
paid you to kick mine if you didn't kick
my ass you were fired you're fired and
when my gym you can't kick my ass if
you're not getting my my ass not getting
kicked you're fired yeah wow that's
that's what you're here for yeah that's
fire you're here to kick my ass i'm not
getting my ass kicked yeah i getting
cause you're not gonna learn you're not
gonna if you're gonna be if you're the
best do your best try to knock me out do
your best
curious though was that with training as
well like weight strength training speed
training
just sparring just sparring i heard me
knock me out
how much you put on that like you say if
you drop me how much do you give him
listen i never put on i told them to do
their best these guys
no one paid foreign partners like i did
well back then or like you did right
what they do
i'm like 2 000 around stuff yeah well
that's a less that's a you ain't a job
after that
so what do you do i spawned mike tyson
for a living [ __ ] bro what
2000 rounds wait what are you fighting
next what's what's the plans you got
anything on the on the line or
people keep asking me what no i want to
know i'm like everyone everyone wants to
know i don't know i just feel good you
enjoy life
um
obstacle course now no way yeah really
like for what just for fun is to prepare
oh real oh i see i see they're prepared
they keep on putting those big prices up
i'm like
it might be worth it hey man yesterday's
price it's not not today today's price
amen amen honestly i said like you
shocked the world when that video with
you and um the guy from kings of me uh
rafael came out like everyone was just
listening that broke the internet i
remember raphael work alright that's why
i got prepared before i go in there with
the visa i've been on the ground
eighth robbie's [ __ ]
on the ground yeah i know you're hitting
the missing
and i just on the [ __ ] ground i'm
like [ __ ] i was saying
i never think what the [ __ ] am i doing
about the [ __ ] i got two more rounds
i threw it around i'm on the floor but
it looked good like that was just
something that wasn't ex like no one
expected that even for me bro so to
watch you and roy fight live
that
was legendary for me because i was there
commentating and there was there was
bits and pieces in there where i was
just like
this is happening holy [ __ ] i'm watching
roy jones fight i'm watching mike tyson
fight this is not supposed to happen
yeah and like i'm not from that era i'm
not from you guys era but i know for a
fact i was living
millions of people's bucket list item
right there yeah just taking that off
and you look good you look good as well
i was just like this is
unreal
and afterwards i went and smoked up with
snoop in the
cable center and then after that then
they take me back to the hotel i
remember being in the bus back just like
hi as [ __ ] just like the [ __ ] is like
there's so many so many things that
happened tonight i get all that they're
smoking who everything they gotta smoke
me i bring a ball on the way and that's
fine
[Laughter]
so that's a stupid [ __ ] i think so let's
put a pound and see what kind of damage
we could do today yeah that's so funny
that you said that because i was it was
actually a day before the game yeah we
were watching it and the whole team was
like right before bed because you know
we had like a curfew before bed we all
stay in this team hotel yeah and legit
the whole team was like down downstairs
in the kitchen area watching the fight
like the whole team legit the whole team
coaches and all i love the production as
well as well cause you had like yg wiz
khalifa yes new perform but then when
you guys came on put on the show it was
just like
this legendary legendary
the reason why um
mma is so um
fast rising because when you go there
unlike fighting when you go there and no
one's fighting there's a party yeah
that's the [ __ ] gets back in the ring oh
everybody's about to understand that
it's not the party really right the next
fight comes then he plays his music the
other guy plays with me they announced
that but till then
vibing yeah definitely even though i
think like one thing i cause i don't
watch sports that's what boxing is it
needs to be a party where there's nobody
in the ring fighting this party even in
basketball whenever i go watch a game i
see like the dj clowning the other team
the away team i never noticed that when
you're watching on tv you don't hear
that kind of stuff but then like when
nothing's happening there's the
cheerleaders there's the dancers it's a
party it's entertainment it's
entertainment so that's what keeps
people going fast facts are [ __ ] so
that's the thing i was fighting because
when i was fighting i knew it was
entertaining yeah the hopkins knew that
he wore the mask and the thing i was the
baddest man in the planet really attack
everybody and it was all entertainment
it brought it brought everybody to the
fight the pokemon everybody filled the
seats yeah yeah that's it
bro
but your time man i don't know what you
were you were giving people problems in
the sense that they just look at what
rounds are going to end it in
like what time like cause you know
someone pays well how much i don't know
how much pay-per-view was back then but
like he's gonna kill him in the first
round he's gonna kill him in the second
round that kind of stuff
yeah that stuff of legends that's the
one you know what's so interesting
i know you're a guy
a champion too when you fight you affect
your level psychological
intellectually and just every uh
anything that um
can be grasped by the human development
that night of the fight is dear like
sometimes i'm in the ring mm-hmm the
fight's going on i could see my friend
getting the letter getting a number from
a girl
really while you're in the ring yeah i
can see that i can see him talking to a
girl and ready for different things i
know what you mean yeah i think i could
hear them
now one thing i definitely i'm grateful
for is selective hearing no matter where
so i fought robert the first time in uh
the biggest sold out arena in ufc
history and no matter how loud the place
is i can always pick out three voices
twister andre and eugene my coach i can
always pick their voice out but as i
walk out i see everything as well
because you're very even you didn't say
the same he's heightened he just sleeps
you're getting ready to fight everything
your senses are dialed up yeah you know
you're on
game day
man
mike [ __ ] you did not see me
[Music]
yeah right then i could see and hear
everything
i love that feeling that's that's i call
that god mode i know they've done like
studies about that where it's
there's um it is it is five different
chemicals in your brain activated when
you're in the zone i feel like when
you're in the zone you just know i
didn't know about the chemical but i
knew that feeling yeah i know the
feeling same i know the feeling you just
know and it's actually you can train
that yes everything's inferior to you
yeah oh you're seeing here everything
you just know what they're gonna do next
like you hear people like me like you
feel like we like with me it's different
like it's like when i put my hand down i
see the guy lined up in front of me like
so wait what position you play yourself
so i play defensive line
yeah i'm on the front lines i play nose
tackle so like it's kind of the same
thing like get in that zone but like
then you start like just picking up on
things like where the like how the
lineman's like putting down their feet
or like or how heavy they are on their
like if they're leaning like so that's
like oh [ __ ] like they're gonna double
team you ever tried sumo wrestling
like the training for it because i've
seen you know like i'm not going to act
like i'm an expert but the positions you
guys get and it reminds me of two big
grizzlies
fighting or two gorillas when they fight
if you ever see gorillas fight it's
almost like sumo wrestling yeah so those
kind of positions you're blocking them
you know pushing each other wrestling i
don't know maybe something you can
explore find you know you might learn
something it's like cross-training what
you would never know about the sumo
wrestler that they're so fragile and i
mean flexible and they can split do all
that kind of in no way yeah they're
athletes they're athletes yeah that's
great flexible real flexible yeah but
try that you know i'm gonna try to
actually have to look at that i do i do
certain things like okay one of the new
things i've been doing
since june last year's breath work
training and i'm telling you man even
even the rock tweeted about it i was
quite surprised about my last fight he
said look at him in the fifth round just
nasal breathing and standing up everyone
else from the second round robert was
sitting down and
breathing but like i'm standing up and
just
and just bringing it down just calming
myself down but it's because the breath
work the pool work it would normally do
it in the pool as well with the weight
vest and there's all these different
protocols but that correlates so well to
fighting yeah cause it's about breathing
yeah and i feel like every athlete could
get into that and and i know everyone's
gonna start to copy you because they see
the benefits of what it's doing for me
and my team yeah i'm telling you if i'm
gonna come in
i would make everybody go through
breathing and mess because if i go to
the bathroom i'm taking the [ __ ] i go
through my breathing method yeah
you have to no it's like you're in labor
it's like you're a laborer you depends
how big it
yeah
is
so how how are you dilated right now
okay let's see the contractions
sick individual yeah
i get around i get it
all right so let's talk about this tweet
this tweet yes by hazmat oh comes out
that's right hamza kumquat no thumbs up
i'm quiet damn yeah i think kobe called
him [ __ ] i never said it
kobe did not me i would never say such a
thing why would i i'm such a nice guy so
he tweeted at you and said at
stylebender easy monday for me zero
wrestling one round i'm gonna kill him
yeah i remember someone said that to me
at the post fight press conference and i
was like okay like end yeah see so like
i feel like when the dog barks at the
moon that's normal but when the moon
blocks at the dog that's something
special so i was like all right this guy
fights at welterweight yeah he's falling
middleweight one time and he's fought
like a low-rank guy yeah and definitely
can beat some middleweights but i'm like
show me something
show me something like he's he's never
his last fight was impressive and i said
i might not like you but if i'm
impressed by what you do i'll give you
props yeah he's a beast but he's a beast
that 170. yeah yeah
when i was champion and these guys
they weren't rain they weren't raided
but they raised me hell they're knocking
out guys and saying i want to fight you
i [ __ ] i said listen um
i mean you won't make no money now but
if you really think you're that tough
why don't you just come to my spot and
become my sparring partner mm-hmm i had
the toughest i had all my sparring
partners were
um contenders
yeah it's all about getting kids about
all out there
trying to knock me out yeah that's what
it is we all try to knock each other out
yeah and look it must be so hard for you
too i'm thinking because mike is a
different time with twitter like guys oh
yeah like guys just like imagine their
time before they had twitter if you guys
had twitter properly while you were
fighting you were active you would have
been a menace on twitter yeah you would
go banned off twitter like six times
definitely
i forgot that think about that mike if
you had twitter because like even alif
ali had twitter imagine the [ __ ] he
would be saying because he was just live
writing his background i was dealing
with my mental problem i don't know oh
man i'm scared i would've ought to be
here for it i'll tell you that much
what is mike saying mike's crazy holy
[ __ ] you said that [ __ ] wow [ __ ]
everybody yeah
no one loves me
oh man no but yeah i like what you said
the same thing because he's a guy like
another guy sean strickland they talk a
lot and right now i'm lapping the
division i need some fresh blood he's
fresh blood bro i'm like show me
something listen yeah show me something
i want to i love what he's doing at 170
baht that's what you need something you
don't need fresh blood
you need you need the guy who the people
think can beat you um exactly people do
costa ri remember costa you know paula
costa before there's a guy fought in a
fight island
same thing same kind of rhetoric
everyone before the fight was like so
the fight before that i fought romero
right and i said this when you fight
someone you and that guy know even when
you play against song you and that guy
know what happens even though they try
and act so romero's actor he was all
theatrics and trying to act like he
wanted to fight but he just became a
statue
and then he fought someone after that in
bellator and everyone was like he did
the same thing he just stood there and
i'm like yeah because he knew if he made
the move i'd [ __ ] him up and i was ready
i was ready so he just stood there and
it was a good game plan i'll give it
i'll give that to him because that let
him land the biggest shot of the fight
which was one shot that should have put
me out put most people out but it didn't
i ate it and i was like cool keep your
distance don't make that mistake again
and i played the long game and i was
waiting for him to do something but he
was just staying there and then after
that fight i remember the rhetoric all
these [ __ ] on twitter all these
reporters oh he's boring he's this down
like [ __ ] i've given you classic after
classic after classic after classic and
then this [ __ ] doesn't want to
fight me and then now you want to talk
this [ __ ] yeah and then the next guy
paula started talking blah blah blah
blah blah he's a shameful champion i'm
going to kill him this and that similar
to what this boy's talking about and i
was like bet
watch this
and i showed them i show them bad i
don't know if you've seen the fight play
the fight for mike just to remind him
yeah play the poll across the fight and
the end i need him to see the end as
well i played prison rules in that fight
that boy wanted static he got started
trust me he got the static and the bag
of chips
and the baggage the chips with the dip
trust me you got the dip
got the dipstick big time
no but that's how it is though so that's
why everyone then
it's it's we're in the era of what have
you done for me lately yeah so people
just like i said i gave you classic
after classic after classic after
classic and then this fight this guy
didn't want to fight me and you're
blaming it on me like i did something
bad go back a bit yeah pause pause go
back a bit so now tell us this like in
your mind what's going on i wanna hear
this so one thing i liked about pause
before you start playing one thing i
liked about it being in the apex this is
during covet time
right and it was um
quiet yeah so it was quiet i love the
fact that you can hear all the strikes
like here when i dropped them i remember
hearing the corner yelling there's one
guy in this corner and i remember him
yelling ah
cause he was undefeated
and and they they were just losing their
[ __ ] and he had to let him know i'm the
big dog in the yard now so i [ __ ] him
up bad ah look at that prison rules
don't get out me odd bro
straight cause i i mean what does a dog
do when you want to show dominance you
pounce on them and you let them know and
i remember like i said i just like the
fact that there was silence and i was
just like i'm gonna oh man and that last
elbow you go back a little bit that last
elbow you see i paused i paused i was
like this is for all that [ __ ] you were
talking
[Applause]
but you look at that last elbow i kind
of paused before i threw it what were
you thinking though what were you
thinking when you when you played that
last elbow i was deciding everything
wait wait for it here
i paused for a split second cause i was
just like this is full oh that [ __ ]
oh yeah you want like a little power up
like a little power you you on that
[ __ ] back yeah oh yeah definitely cause
everyone was talking all this [ __ ] after
that last fight saying like oh israel's
so boring all he does is run away he's
never had i'm like [ __ ] you i said
classic after classic after classic
after classic and this is how you guys
want to talk because you have [ __ ]
goldfish memories yeah so and i remember
saying y'all must have forgot so i had
to remind them and there's coach over
there eric i told him i called him over
him you know why i went over to the
corner right and i said hey i i
appreciate what you've done with harry
cejudo you really brought him up and
then he goes oh we're coming for
volkanovsky next and i'm like [ __ ] i'm
coming all over you cause i try to give
him props about what he's done for for
him you know henry i try to say like you
brought him up nice and then he was
still trying to get that static against
my guy alex and i was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'll show you how it is
yeah i don't worry i play i play i play
rough when it's time man i like the
energy yeah i mean i keep that same
energy like when people try to fight me
and [ __ ] with me i let them know this is
the shadow self you know what
those guys that you beat and stuff that
get you angry to get you in that mood
they can't sell coca-cola they can't
sell coca-cola you're a nice guy you're
smart intelligent guy if you don't act
too crazy you're too emotional you can
sell [ __ ] yeah yeah spokesman i am i
guess i guess i'm just my guy right
there tim he he hooks me up with some
nice some nice things example i'm the
first um mma fighter to be signed by
puma yeah you know what i mean and one
thing i love
i never expected that i thought maybe
like one day
because i think jones had nike till he
became one of them guys and
all that stuff and then
had her taken away from him but me i
like the fact that puma [ __ ] with me
they [ __ ] with the way i express myself
they see like
this guy is not afraid to say what he
wants to say he's a cool dude he
expresses himself authentically we [ __ ]
with him and they've never had a problem
with anything i've said anything i've
tweeted they've just been cool and they
respect because they know i'm not going
to embarrass them and they know like
they know me i've met the team now i
went to puma in boston about a week and
a half ago and i touched base with them
and i was surprised they would even they
were asking me opinions on some of the
pieces that's coming out this year yeah
next year and i'm just like man i [ __ ]
with these dudes so yeah yeah i i can
sell some stuff but at the same time i
never want to sell myself i never want
to sell myself because of a
paycheck like that's real i've had we've
had issues in the past with other brands
and other people trying to say oh you
can't say that i'm like well [ __ ] you
i'll find someone who can who
appreciates me because i can just speak
my truth i agree yeah i just sell me
yeah exactly you've experienced you've
spent that you experienced that michael
you had that as well i realized i found
that my brand is bigger than all the
brands i was trying to be a part of yeah
brother you know like trust you you're
mike tyson what the hell was i doing
yeah yeah yeah
you kept doing the groupie stuff
fanboy stuff and this is my stuff
they've got uh j cole you know they've
got a neymar you know big names what's
his name lamelo yeah i'm like these are
guys that are creative and you see
they're not they're not cookie cutter
i've never been one of these guys who
there's certain guys especially in new
zealand when when the when the rugby
teams win i can tell you their their
speech right afterwards give me an
example you know how's the game today oh
we did very good just want to uh thank
the big man upstairs for giving us the
strength we played really good and um
the other team brought it and yeah you
know thanks to our coaches thanks to my
mom and i'm like bro you just won like
if you just won the super bowl right
yeah i'm late
[Applause]
i'm that guy too yeah but then this guy
this woman right here is gonna suck me
my great grandkids up for the rest of
their life yeah cause this is what i
have to be i can't be that guy right now
yeah facts no i understand you have you
have to make that choice one day that's
what i said about balance like i don't
know
that great last year emotion yeah and
the thought you have facts like i said i
want to express myself even you see
after that fight i i [ __ ] up costa
double tap him and i'm i'm cracking my
windmills on the ground that's me
expressing myself and some people might
not like it but i'm like you're going to
watch it anyway i wasn't hurting anyone
i was literally just dancing because i
just knocked out a guy that was talking
mad [ __ ] about me for the last [ __ ] i
don't know
that's just no because i was that guy
too yeah no but you were that guy you
know i wanted to be the king of the
savages yeah but uh price comes with
that yeah definitely that's why i say i
was saying like early on i can't live in
that mode for too long because if i do
then i start i find myself like look
being in it all time bro it's hard like
okay so when i'm in camp i don't know if
you'll like this i don't even know if
you'll like this as well because it's
all battle or talk competition
when it's three weeks before the fight i
find myself starting to detach and maybe
disassociate from my loved ones not
crazy
but because i kind of have to go within
i know i'm going to war my body knows
what's coming my mind and soul knows
what's coming so i find myself
my mom calls me i don't pick it up all
the time or i'll be i'll call you back
but they don't take it personal i still
talk to them but just not as often as i
would yeah and then after the fight it
takes about two weeks maybe a week now
for them to get me back to just my old
yeah happy-go-lucky self that's so funny
you say that [ __ ] girl i know exactly
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
listen that's crazy that's how i come i
used to get in a lot of trouble yeah
imagine you gotta take i get all this
pumps and boom 30 seconds over i still
got that where are we at
[Applause]
now backstage and busting up real quick
it might still be there maybe no it's
got as long as more than a nut dude
everyone's going for hours
listen
once you're in that move [ __ ] means
nothing to you yeah yeah you're falling
in love with yourself when you're
getting that boom
good enough for you it's so true the way
i look at it with us is a little
different so we play sundays yeah so
like with me it's like
so tuesdays are our off day yeah so it
that [ __ ] doesn't wear off till like
monday
monday it starts wearing off a little
bit monday after the game but then you
watch the film and like you start
recalling the plays and you're like
all the good [ __ ] you did like yeah yeah
i did this i did that and then tuesday
it's kind of when i'm able to like get
that yeah calm down and like and then
just rams back you ever had that before
because i've had this um my uh i've
talked about this on other
interviews my first ufc fight ufc 221
perth australia
i go in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] up make another bonus gang a
little money at the after party i'm
getting pulled left right in the center
after the fight i'm pulled left right
and center for interviews interviews
because i i was i was in the main event
but i stole the show guarantee i stole
the show
and then a few days later after that i
finally end up back in my house
in new zealand and i remember getting
depressed for like two weeks i don't
know if you've ever had that because i i
equate it to like coffee when you drink
coffee coffee's a stimulant it gets you
all the way up and then you crash
so for me i felt like i this is when i
started to go to therapy properly and
kind of like trying to figure myself out
and kind of i guess biohack myself yeah
so i was like all that stimulus was just
like
you know everything and then when i
finally yeah
i was high all that stuff so when i got
back home and i realized and i was like
why am i sad there's no [ __ ] reason
to be sad i just made six figures in my
first ufc fight i'm here i'm [ __ ] i'm
the man i'm like then why am i [ __ ]
depressed so that's when i started to
kind of see someone and i was wondering
like have you ever had something like
that where you felt like it was up and
then you you get away from it and then
you had to like figure out like
that's that's i feel that's where some
people get into a trap yeah they don't
realize like what's wrong with them or
what not wrong what's happening so they
figure like i'm gonna go go out and try
and fill that up with like going out and
partying with the wrong people doing
drugs and alcohol and that kind of stuff
yeah see that's not in your mind that's
in your soul sure
i feel like someone from a little kid we
want to become famous and famous but we
don't know why but it's to fill that
dark little hole that we have
and we don't know how the more famous we
get the more powerful we get the deeper
the whole gets yeah you never know they
ain't trying to fill that hole with the
wrong things
so that's what yeah i've learned that
like so there's that's why i said like i
was like i need to go see someone about
this and that's what my journey with
therapy started so i can like okay let
me figure out what this was and then i
got some tools from that that helped me
by my fourth ufc fight this was in new
york madison square garden i got back
home and i felt like i was able to just
kind of roll into my life swiftly and
not be like
you know off that adrenaline and all
that stuff and then come back home and
i'm down i just knew what to do so i had
the tools and the knowledge of okay this
is how i need to get back into life and
that made me kind of just
go back into my life easy but it took a
while it took a while and i don't really
struggle with that anymore but yeah yeah
you ever had that before no i know what
you're talking about because
it is a high like you know like if you
have like a great game like i remember
explaining it's kind of like when you
have a great game and then
you know you're just so high on it like
you're celebrating you know you let's
say i got like 10 tackles a sack i
remember like one game i had a ten
tackle i had like ten tackles a sack
yeah uh like four qb hits that's a good
game and i'm a nose so that's really
good for like a nose tackle and it was
kind of the same thing like i'm high off
it high off of it
and it kind of does like that tuesday
then that tuesday hit your off day
you're kind of like
oh [ __ ] like yeah bam but you have to be
okay with that yeah
you got to be able to be okay with that
and i think as competitors what happens
is
we want to be great at whatever we're
doing so much facts that like
when we're not doing something like when
we like when we do have that like just
that time the yeah just with yourself
yeah you're like [ __ ] like what like
don't give me too much this is back in
the day i'm a lot better i'm more mature
now but maybe two years ago i'd say
don't give me too much time off because
i'll find something to get into because
i just like i'm an adrenaline junkie no
listen this is what i know if that's
what you believe then that would happen
exactly if you gonna believe you don't
have no time you're gonna get in trouble
you'll get in trouble that was two years
ago though that was two years where i
was not that was back then i was like
don't give me too much time off now i
can have all the time off i know what to
do yeah i know where to be i stay in the
gym i stay with my people and then that
way it keeps me growing you could say
none of this stuff out here is worth
what i can do for my family my children
in 10 years facts facts where you're
building the stuff you'll build
everything i do right now i'm sure same
you have any kids no i don't have any
kids too not that i know
[Laughter]
not but like everything i do right now
is for my future family that's gonna be
interesting too when you have kids yeah
and they're gonna show you what you're
made out of cause you're gonna see the
part of your life where you hide comes
out in numb facts facts now that's one
thing i've learned is um childhood
trauma's like i didn't realize this
until probably be about
a year and a half ago everyone on this
planet you you everyone in this room has
childhood traumas that they haven't
addressed and
somehow we try and fill that up with
other things until they come to the
surface love brings that to the surface
normally sometimes psychedelics
sometimes another trauma will bring that
to the surface and you're like [ __ ] i've
been dealing with this for the last 30
years and i didn't even realize i was
holding this because of some [ __ ] that
happened when i was five years old yeah
and you don't realize that cause you
just bury it you just deep down in your
subconscious it's just dug deep but
there's a ways like i said love
psychedelics and sometimes other trauma
brings that to the surface and before
you know it you're forced to deal with
it i've had some i've had my fair share
of having to deal with my
childhood traumas in the last two years
and i'm glad that i did because if i
didn't i wouldn't be where i'm at right
now i wouldn't be as i guess maybe
insightful as i am right now i'm still
working on it no one's [ __ ] just i'm
never perfect
well it's always a
learning procedure so i feel like it's
like a like a threshold
there's good and there's bad and there's
the balance in there you're always
trying to lean towards the good or find
balance
but then sometimes life will just do
something that'll knock you towards that
other side where you just do you do
mushrooms i have i like them the last
time i did mushrooms actually was before
the costa fight
so this is before the fight no no no no
this is like maybe three weeks before
the [ __ ] thanks for the fight i'll tell
you the story right so that we're we're
quarantined right we're quarantined in
the gym because we're on lockdown so me
and my team we lock down in the gym and
we're living in the gym for that whole
camp yeah and one day it was a sunday so
we did a spider session this is the
hardest workout of the week that's like
it simulates the fight and after that
me
decide let's go for a bike ride and then
we just did some mushrooms and it was
one of the best
[ __ ] days ever i still i played
that's why i came out to one of my
fights uh summertime mannedlist
cooling the gang because on the on the
bike ride i just had that on my
headphones on repeat and then we stopped
at a park i remember when one part we
just started sparking up smoking some
weed and these bikers rolled by and we
just looked at ourselves and looked at
them and started laughing because i look
at these tough guys
and then
we went to mount eden this is a spot in
auckland
and on the way up i i i so on the way up
i remember thinking like [ __ ]
i don't want to go up because my oh my
scooter ran out of battery so i had to
uber to the mount eating i told the boys
i'd meet them there and then i put my
scooter in the bush and i remember
thinking like it was just going to be a
few people but i forgot it's locked down
everybody and the mom and their dog's
going to be there so i was like [ __ ] i
don't want to go up i'm going to be
[ __ ] with and i was like nah [ __ ] this
i'm not gonna let people just take away
the joys of life of just walking up a
mountain so i was like i'm just gonna
put my hoodie up and walk up and i
remember just putting my hoodie up
and walking up and no one could see me
knowing to talk to me and then i
remember getting to the top and this is
just when the sun was setting
and then i remember looking up and just
woof
and i took my hoodie off like what the
[ __ ] i could see the sunset and i was
just like
holy [ __ ] and this is the peak the peak
of the trip
and i was just like whoa
and looking at it and i remember it was
just like the landscape
was engulfing the sun and there was this
pink orange purpley hue just like
squirting out of the like the landscape
and it was just like that was a clouds
it was like it was like a live painting
in front of me like god was painting in
front of me live and as i was watching
it there was bits and pieces i wasn't
the only one because it was a bit where
something exploded in the sky and i
heard whoa
i looked over and i was like they know
like we're seeing the same [ __ ] and this
black english
staffordshire terrier pulled up next to
me and the owners looked at me and i was
like that's cause we're black and then
he just sat right next to me i just sat
there and looked at the sun saying just
pat him
and i just pat him and then we were just
chilling for a little bit and after that
when the sun set finally just got
engulfed by the sky
then that was it bounced god damn that
was beautiful
that was my last trip and that was
that was my last mushroom trip it's been
a while i like to keep times in between
because like i said there's certain
lessons i learned from them and certain
feelings yeah like i said that track
whenever i play that track now cool in
the gang summertime madness it just it
reactivates the feeling yeah like oh
just that sense of like i remember where
my brain was at on that trip and it was
[ __ ] yeah it was beautiful man i love
that that's fine i'm overdue for another
trip eventually it happened but i never
like i don't force it it just whenever
like
it calls me whenever i just you just
know he just knows me every day oh yeah
hey man
i don't know about that my man goes deep
yeah
that's fire though that's dope so let's
talk about this big push for fighter pay
yeah in the ufc like do you believe that
fighters should be fairly poor 100
percent
after this fight right
i made uh my team at paradigm and also
ap sports management we secured you know
one of the biggest deals in in ufc
history in mma history
and i was already speaking about this
because you know everyone's been talking
about shout out to my boy my big brother
francis
he became he kicked the door down just
said look this is what's happening they
pay me this much and i'm this guy and
how you know
he put it all out there yeah like mike
imagine at the height of a career when
you were mike tyson still on mike tyson
but you were fighting and you're getting
paid
the equivalent of 600k to fight that
would be atrocious i wouldn't i wouldn't
know nothing um that'd be my training
expenses it's crazy gone
that's my training it's gone even like
for me this whole world tour i've been
looking after everyone i don't i don't
care but like you know i'm sure tim can
tell me how much i've spent on this trip
already if you wanted to do the math but
like these are things i feel like no
it's not about me
all i'm saying is like look the guys who
are making their debut
you know like one of my teammates blood
diamond made his debut some other people
who are making their debut i'm like they
should be able to just get paid
and then not have to work at all during
their training camps because a lot of
fighters do they work imagine having a
second job [ __ ] crazy yeah you
shouldn't know you shouldn't so get paid
pay their manager or management pay
their training expenses and then have
enough to live on hey listen yeah
i would go out there and give you my
training expenses right i would go out
partying all my friends all my living
parties and i'm hanging out party and
everything and then um
when it comes time the fight said listen
if we don't cancel the fight i won't i'm
not going to fight
i said i'm not going to fight so i
cancelled the fight but
if you give me um
six months i'll fight again but if not
you're saying this whole fight would you
want to cancel the fight so that was
late they feel like fighting one of the
parties
yeah yeah fair enough and somebody and
that's the hey i forgot so they they
cancel the fight and they have to pay me
back really
oh that was a mess and nobody wanted to
deal with me no i could tell you [ __ ]
they didn't want to deal with me and
stuff
people would pay me to do like
commercials they paid me in advance and
somebody might like
something you were like y'all keep that
for myself
when i was young i was just a master
yeah now well um that's one thing i'm
glad about for myself is i'm glad i
didn't find fame young mm-hmm i'm glad i
didn't find fame at 24. did you find it
i felt like i kind of got famous maybe
27 okay yeah 26. you were more mature
more mature yeah still a little [ __ ]
sometimes because you know i'm human you
know we're all human like there's one
thing i learned this this training camp
i had the epiphany
there's no good
or bad people
people are
capable of great good or great evil
that's what i've learned because
everyone likes to feel like this
narrative especially before this last
fight like i felt like
i was the heel
you know what i mean like i was supposed
to be in that role because rob is the
good guy he's this he's the how could
you hate rob he's i'm like
i know i know him he's a piece of [ __ ]
sometimes the first time he fought me he
was a little [ __ ] he was cocky he was
throwing a little shade at me a little
smirk this time he couldn't say [ __ ]
cause i knocked him out the first time
so he just like he was humble he was
somber even he said like yeah he's got
bragging rights so he just he approached
me differently for this fight yeah and
then jeff my videographer
he even mentioned that the reason i
[ __ ] him up the first time is because
of the static
because whenever i have static with
someone i go at them different but this
time
he was somber humble
he wouldn't
poke the bear at all because he knew
what happened even when i okay so i get
in the cage right in the octagon and i
do the circle around the octagon
and i wasn't going to touch him then he
puts his hand out like he submitted to
me and i remember just smacking his hand
like i dapped him up
in his head yeah
i'm not loud no but i had to wait i had
to wait
no cause i i don't touch gloves even i
feel like when the fight starts i i
don't touch gloves because you know what
that's the first point of contact you
establish the range right away so i
don't want to touch gloves i would
establish the range my own way i don't
want to give him an inch at all so the
fact that when i was doing my circle
around the around the cage he goes like
that and i just slapped it like the [ __ ]
you give me your hand for like [ __ ] i'm
about to fight you so he came at me with
that energy because he didn't want to
poke the beer and i've said this already
a few interviews and people are going to
think like oh i'm just going to be nice
to him before i find him he's not going
to kick my ass wrong i'm going to figure
it out i've already i'm on my way
already because
i see i got the chips and the dip man i
tell you like when i've when i've seen
the last dance and the way jordan
approached the game there's times that i
felt that way and i'll just like i'll
like the first time i fought him he made
this stupid meme he's never he never
talks [ __ ] about anyone anyone ever
before he fights them then he makes a
stupid meme about me and i was like why
the [ __ ] are you making a meme about me
like what the [ __ ] is that supposed to
be and that let me know that showed me
his hand early like you're acting out of
character
and i held on to that meme and then took
it personal i took impressions where the
jordan
personally like literally so i held on
to that and a few other little shitty
things he did along that that that
training camp i remember i'm gonna hold
on to that i'ma remember that this time
he gave me nothing he gave me nothing
but i'ma find a way don't worry i
already know like okay this is something
that i need to address i don't need to
have static to beat someone up or [ __ ]
them up to the worst degree possible i
can find a way to to get that
that reptilian brain unlocked so i can
get at them without needing to hold on
to something there's ways if i can do it
[ __ ] up or if if someone is um you
know coming at me differently and i can
do it you know whenever i want to just
based on my skills yeah yeah so i'll
lock it so let's talk about your boy
usman who's mom my brother is he pound
for pound yeah the best fighter he's the
best he's playing covington again no no
he like he already beat covington twice
so he's kind of watching that he's
lapping the division as well so he's
doing that at 170. i'm doing that 185
he's lapping the division and i know
he's got the powerful pound rankings but
look i'll put him up there he's probably
the best fighter active right now yeah
i'll give it to him and i'm not one of
these guys who gets like because people
ask me so before he won the belt i
hadn't won the belt yeah i was scheduled
to fight for the bill and someone some
reporter asked me like do you hope he
loses his title shot so you can be the
first nigerian and i was just like yuck
why would i
i've never been one of those guys to
like i hope he loses his chance at the
belt so i can be the first legend
yeah oh this guy's a beast
honestly i'm the runt of my people look
at him and look at francis and look at
me
bro i know i work but i'm skinny and i'm
i'm like the run no i feel pretty
shredded though yeah i know trust me i i
puts it down but like these guys are the
pigs
beefcake like you go around nigeria
you'll find five of these within a block
trust trust like you find and this is
with like not the best nutrition in some
of these streets even in cameroon and
south africa like just the genetic
specimens of africans are different man
i'm telling you it's different you can
see it in black americans and black
africans and haitians and jamaicans
that's true like it's different so i
know when i go back home i see i just
see it i'm like damn i know i'm the runt
because i am the wrong i was never
athletic all that kind of stuff i was
just good at dancing and i liked video
games and jackie chan movies yeah so i
was like yo i can be a fighter too an
animal right anime i love anime that's
rudolph yeah naruto i grew up right no
way i was broke on that [ __ ] i grew up
on that [ __ ] definite man dragon ball z
all that [ __ ] yeah man like i mean i i
love that
that's the story marvel comics
random question right you live in l.a
now well where you live
in vegas
my mind's everywhere it's outside you're
outside
we just moved here for our daughter's
tennis career okay now we're moving to
florida i guess from
in the next month for her
consideration also daughter plays tennis
yeah she's really good yeah she's
beautiful
that's awesome do you still like
have your pigeons around do you still
holding everywhere i go i have pigs no
really if i go somewhere like oh here i
have i have a picnic about build one you
oh so you build them you build like a
coop or uh wherever i go damn okay i see
yes i love that relationship can't live
without them yeah now i've i've seen
i've seen well your documentaries and my
first fight was because of the page i
remember you said the guy bit his head
off or did something ah crazy
well lucky
yeah i only had a pigeon once when i was
a kid for a school project and i
remember
so
my housemate tied a string to its leg
and attached it to a little stick so it
couldn't fly away but then after the
school project after the school project
we had to let it go so we let it go but
it kept on coming back
came back every day and i'd feed him and
everything and he would come back
probably for about a month and
eventually never saw him again the hook
partly's at him oh real i see yeah true
this is back in nigeria too i see it but
it was coming back every day for like a
month
eagles got a bunch of everything
out there
oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah definitely not african 11 years
[Music]
hey dad what animal you think kills more
people than
all the animals in the world i found
some kind of bug mosquito you know it
was a mosquito yeah
lying mosquito had malaria probably like
six to eight times six to eight times
yeah so this is a mutant in there yeah
and nigeria was like this is normal
normal but it's a [ __ ] up feeling like
you're lying in bed you're cold you're
hot you're sweating
and you're also just shivering and
delirious as well at the same time and
your your muscles are weak and it can be
like that for a week
maybe sometimes people die that's the
biggest thing that's what i'm saying it
kills you so i've had it like six six to
eight times i'm sure as a kid are you
different bro so let's talk about uh
what are your thoughts on jon jones ooh
john whatever john whatever happened to
john man john is a is a problem to his
own self his own damn self and i don't i
mean i only speak about him because you
actually bought him yeah
i wouldn't talk about him there was a
clip there was a clip i saw
maybe a year ago this is just after
costco so far just before the cost if i
came out of him
apparently he was shooting guns around
the strip club and then he got arrested
yeah i know crazy
yeah you never hey you can't tip
strippers with bullets man it's that's
different but um yeah she can't make her
love you man you can't make her love you
dance baby pop pop
you [ __ ] you ain't dance
me
it might have been but then there was a
clip like this of him getting arrested
talking to the officer on the first name
basis and i remember just thinking i was
like man i felt sorry for him was he
hurting him or something yeah he smacked
his head on the bonnet so this is the
one that was recent after he got
inducted into the hall of fame
and then
went back to his hotel room apparently
and
who do you hate his wife or his fiance
and his daughter now yeah no and his
daughter had to like go downstairs with
his with her mom and be like you know
call the cops imagine that that's that
you know that's not the first time
that's happened and uh it's yuck man
that's just having to even speak on this
because
he's a guy that when he first came up i
remember watching him at ufc 94 he
fought he fought stephen bonner and that
was the first time i saw him fight on
pay-per-view live and i was like yo this
guy's special yeah he is and i was a fan
of him yeah and he was a fan of me to
realize he wanted to fight me and then
he became not a fan and we had this
before while and the fight never
transpired yet but then when i see [ __ ]
like this even this one when i saw this
i felt like i'm i'm empathetic i'm a
human being you know sure yeah i'm like
man
what a waste what a waste of potential
also the fact that he's been popped for
steroids have i mean everybody listen
everybody can't handle god's gift now
he's his own worst enemy man and this is
the thing i've made mistakes mike look
i'm a human being like i said there's no
good or bad people people are just
capable of great good or great evil i've
done some bad things in myself i've made
some mistakes but i learned from those
mistakes i don't make the same mistakes
over
and over and over again and that's why
knock on wood i've never ended up on tmz
for a bad reason
you know i mean could not cause like
he's been on tmz for the for how many
times just for the wrong reasons and
it's just sad to see men like some of
the most successful people have the
lowest selfish names faster believe that
facts the most successful that's why
because every low self-esteem that's why
facts i've been there because when i was
coming up in new zealand you know like i
said being the only one of the only
black kids in the school in the town
survival mechanism for me was
people-pleasing
and i realized it read this ugly head in
my adult world a little bit mm-hmm and
now i know how to kill it whenever i
feel it or having to conform to their
culture or whatever bro
i'm just trying to talk like them i have
to try and do this like literally and i
realized like bro i don't even look like
you were am i trying to sound like yeah
i don't even like and i realized like
i'm not supposed to fit in i'm meant to
stand out i was never meant to fit in so
that was one of the things that helped
me get over that hump and like i said it
was it's something i can't believe i
thought john jones smashed his head in
that car
yeah i can't believe canada's one hell
of a drug mike cocaine is one hell of a
drug i thought they had i i didn't know
i was asking just you know because i
know you know i thought you all were
gonna fight at one point
i mean just you know the knight's still
young put it that way yeah but yeah he's
uh he's his own i mean fight francis
he's been talking about going in
heavyweight for the last since 2013. i
said it and i did it i don't just talk
about it yeah i did it i went up in a
weight class he's never yeah he can i'm
like yo go fight
he's from a religious family he needs to
surround himself with the right people
and not say this is god's test for me
you know no yeah this is not god's
testimony give you around how much of
religion if you're not ready for him
he's not coming nah
like oh that's a mask or like i said how
he came into this game or not just him
as well i say other people you've seen
the other athletes other actors or
actresses they come in and trying like
tupac said the baby said something about
being a role model that's the fakest two
things in the world because you're
you're playing a role and you're
modeling your behavior so i've always
said that's why i love like guys like
puma who [ __ ] with me because i'm not
someone's role model i'm not people are
like yes you know
no but i'm not i'm not complaining you
can't choose i'm not but i'm not that
controlled i know i know they're trying
to
follow me
okay mike you know i can't i can't
know i'll tell you okay i'll tell you i
have no control over this i'm not a role
model but even like these two these two
no no no i i'm not i won't say i'm not
trying to act like a role model to put
it that way no your accomplishments your
skills made you a role model
automatically me being myself made me a
role model okay but what i'm saying is
like the way he was back in the day when
he was sponsored by nike all that he
used to be all this like oh you know
thank god
john he'd be behaving this certain way
and then like behind the scenes acting a
different way i am the same way on
camera it's up to you that comes back to
haunt you yeah
those partners when you're bullshitting
god created [ __ ] facts
yeah but like for me
no but like since i've been in this game
i would
i've never been a guy to try and fake
anything that's not faking there's
people just like you they
they
you're their role model yeah oh no but
i'll take that and like i said there's
kids out there that i know personally
and i know their dad like example i've
used this example of zion um harrison
and spencer these kids who go to my gym
and they they look up to me they they
really appreciate me and this i'll show
you a picture of um says harrison before
you had his um tonsils out his dad gave
him an action figure of myself
this is him
pre-op
and that's him post-op and he's with an
action figure of myself oh wow and his
his dad you know
allows them to watch me with the way i
carry myself with the way i speak with
the way i express myself and
to them i'm a role model and i for me i
never want to let them down i never want
them to hang their head in shame because
i end up on something like that looking
stupid so i i do my best to just be me
and i never want to put put that kind of
shame on them but at the same time i
just uh i hate i just hate the word i
think we need a new name for it i need a
new right because it's like park said it
best
role model like you're playing a role
and you're acting you know why because
you feel you're you're not worthy of
that um position you're feeling your
heart you're not what no exactly
to be a role model i have felt that and
that's like that way that imposter
syndrome comes in and i've had to deal
with that as well where i felt like man
why do these kids love me so much they
don't know they're like hey just like
that's why who did you so who did you
see that you say hey i can't be a
fighter
prince naseem addison silva i listen
yeah and it's a wrap it's over
it's over yeah
well i just don't like that word i don't
like that one or two israelites honda
there you go yeah i know what you think
in the book yeah it is it is yeah i know
i can't i can't take away from it i
can't run away from it i understand okay
i think it's a terminology you guys
don't want the responsibility no no no
i'll role models i'll take it no i'll
take it like i said i would never end up
there knock on wood again i will never
end up there but we're not gonna work it
we never know exactly
yeah i just i think it's just the term
of it like because i never want to be
fake i never want to be that guy so the
fact that those kids look up to me
would just mean living myself being
authentically me
that's that makes me feel good that
makes me enough for me but the same time
definition of fake
thanking somebody and not being doing
somebody else exactly well that's what
you you're not doing that so why are you
worrying about being a role model you're
not doing that so that's that's
beautiful you're doing everything you
want to do you're a role model you're
putting that out there
okay you know what i'm listening i'm
listening i think you're right because i
don't want to be fake i don't want to be
a guy that has that bestowed upon them
and also there was not now but there was
that feeling of like they don't really
know me why do i feel like i deserve
there was a little bit of imposter
syndrome i've had to deal with in the
past no it's not calling positivism it's
called the form it's called formula
self-hate yeah that's what's going on
yeah from childhood trauma that's what
that's what we all have that's what
elevates us yeah it is it's a form of
self-hate just a little bit elevates us
but yeah like for me uh you might have
you you've you've done what they call a
paradigm shift a little bit i have to
sit with it i have to sit with it and
really ponder and just think about it
shampoo you should accept yeah i want to
my cat
okay where i have to think about i have
to i have to
paradigm shift that's at least the
beginning no such thing as suffering
it's only self-suffering yes nothing
doesn't exist it's only from the self
yes yes himself but it's a paradigm
shift that's a cure so i'm like okay let
me sit with this and just okay accept
that because i mean look you're mike
tyson you've been through all my
paradigm shift is what i'm not a street
[ __ ] no more yeah
no i'm not going to rob nobody mm-hmm
that was yours yeah
that's that's what i love doing i don't
have to survive i love robbing people
yeah you don't have to survive anymore
what age did you have that
all my life really what age did you have
that shift that paradigm shift 14 really
that's when you're unboxing yeah was
that from costco yeah [ __ ]
okay i know i could have the world um
he put that in my mind he made that
reality okay
hmm no i have to okay i have to accept
this new way of being maybe no it's not
a new way it's going to happen to you it
is yeah i mean it was you before you
were even existing
it was it was written it was written
guys like i said they accept me for me
so i'm like i'm i'm only being yeah
check that peep game
they accept you for you you gotta accept
you for me yeah i am i'm learning i'm
learning too they accept you whatever
you give them they're gonna accept
that's what you have to imagine whatever
you give them thing i'm scared of being
ending up like that that's one of my
worst fears oh yeah oh my goodness he
has every embrace
yeah any athletes
even like that free britney documentary
that was one of the most
triggering things for me to watch i
don't know if you've seen it free
brittany so britney spears pretty much
her release from being in a
conservatorship and i remember watching
one of the clips
in the beginning of the documentary when
she's driving around these streets
trying to get away from paparazzi and
this guy was filming her going like look
at her she just ran a red light what a
crazy [ __ ] and i remember just feeling
like cause you're [ __ ] chasing her
that's why she's trying to run away from
you listen she wanted the baddest
[ __ ] in this country man theo and
they're fighting for freedom yeah that's
what i mean like that's what that whole
documentary was about that's that's real
she's gonna do it
yeah that's not um what's that little
song she didn't give it to me no this is
real man
and honestly that's kicking his ass yeah
she did and then she's free from it now
yeah see this is live she's just what
you need to watch i've seen it freedom
this is her instagram
oh no she living living look at her yeah
that's right yeah she's outside
that's really outside
we can't get brittany on this show yeah
i would love to nah she definitely have
stories for free imagine fighting
against someone that put you in the
third world yes
you're making them tens of millions of
dollars a year and they're giving you an
allowance of 2 000 a month
of your own money i do all this for my
children [ __ ] eldest stuff whatever
kids as well that was another thing to
see her kids she had to ask permission
to see her kids
that's [ __ ] man we all make mistakes
when we're young yeah we and we try to
even up with ourselves
amen there's no good or bad people we're
just capable of great good or great evil
no i'm not malevolent i'm not i just am
whatever i am about
exactly exactly that's it we just are i
am that's when i hate people saying like
i'm a good person i'm a bad person no
you just are i am who i am i am going to
do what we do yes that's life so let's
talk about conor mcgregor his comeback
my julie fighting what are you doing you
have to ask the guy right there so we're
under the same management
he just comes back and i'm going for the
belt straight away [ __ ] everybody else
that's the thing he he has the pulling
power to do that yeah cause he he's
conor mcgregor as a former champion but
and i i like what gaichi said even
though he's like what do you say if i
don't fight for the belt we riot and i
was like yeah because gay she just like
deserves to fight for the belt now he's
fighting for the belt but conor's living
life right now man look at him he's just
living life living he's living his best
life and i know he's training i see he's
always lifting stays in shape stays
ready as he likes to say but
yeah man we'll see they
start to stay ready with that lifestyle
bro hey man i'll tell you something
people people have been saying that but
i haven't felt that yet even with this
new contract i have not felt that at all
that rockstar lifestyle no i know i have
but like that feeling of like oh what
does it look great marvin hogg marvin
hagler said it's hard to get up wasn't
marvin that said that when you sleep in
silk sheets
something like that i haven't felt that
i felt that a little bit in the past but
lately never felt that because i'm
hungry
yeah you ever have a 30 million dollar
fight
not yet
not yet then then then talk to me later
when you're gonna see those levels
there's levels
levels to the [ __ ] that's right when you
get a 40 million dollar fight and the
week after you got that 40 million and i
tell you you gotta fight in like six
weeks it's hard to get out to bed you
say how much money from no but for me
five more million
look 10 million dollars 40 million
dollars at a certain point it's just
money like literally i don't i don't
know it'll hit you i see them hit my
accounts but it's just like
it's just money to me i'm fine i know
i'm set for i could have been set for
life i couldn't if it was just about
money i'd have left this game three
three three fights ago you love this
just i love it i love you i'm learning
right now i love learning learning
learning what money can do
learning how it grows if you plan it
right yeah that's where my pups comes in
that's honestly like so in december just
over this christmas i went home and my
pops is like you know he's he's the guy
that
like khabib's dad was on the on on the
field with him he was helping him steph
chad jordan's that my pups was behind
the scenes helping me make my money grow
make my money work for me and he sat me
down and told me how much i was worth
and my joy hit the floor i was like yo
for real he's like yeah
i was just like [ __ ] we could have
stopped this [ __ ] ages ago if we if it
was just about money but it's not just
about money for me like i said i am
young i am fresh i am hungry and i want
to [ __ ] these [ __ ] up while i
can because there's going to be a day
when it's like okay i had another
epiphany during the costa camp like i
said we were quarantined in the gym and
remember it was a saturday for sparring
and i was watching everyone just put
their wraps on put their shin guards on
and i remember just pausing for a second
that i put my wraps on just being like
look at us like it was just a moment of
just like
gladiators warriors getting ready for
battle i was like i can't do this [ __ ]
forever so while i'm doing this [ __ ] i'm
gonna enjoy it i'm gonna really
soak it in and i've used this quote like
j cole said applying pressure mm-hmm
before the end of this game i really
want to apply pressure and make sure i
get everything done and money's going to
come money's always going to come
like i don't i don't struggle you know
money does come because this is what i
was just trying to say
the art of
business
it's getting the most money with the
less risk
you're always fighting killers next yeah
fight some fight some hot coming up um
brazilian a nice white guy that's come
up and got a big background that you
could easily get killed you need some
easy fights no the cat they can't do
that in the ufc like in the ufc and
boxing or kickboxing that's that's easy
with the blueprint they can do that but
in the ufc with dana everybody you fight
is a killer he's a [ __ ] he's a
guy that can beat you so i have i have
already uh i've like i've lapped already
dude
yeah it's more
profitable they have to they know what
they don't do and um this is really
interesting yeah they won't get a guy
who has a little bit of talent i don't
know white guy
like poor blonde hair blue eyes little
knock out a bunch of guys and boom
that's the multi super fight
hmm who's the guy that can do that
they've ah
he can fight he's not a bum he could
fight a guy fight a little bit connor
can fight conor was a gangster conor
came in and just took over he literally
just came in just [ __ ] everybody up in
this way he really yeah he did he did
whatever he did he would still be the
man he is because of his character's
personality yeah his soul who he is
people follow his prayer they don't give
a [ __ ] about him
support him they are supportive
facts facts
so your thoughts on jake paul my guy
jake i like jake yeah i like jake he's
cool actually i'm trying to link up with
him i don't know if he's he's [ __ ]
he's everybody's in puerto rico he's not
hey
want something over the place no but he
uh he hit me up
that's right i saw that picture you guys
linked up in new year's or something
yeah but um yeah we'll link up all of my
hair if we have time i like jake i like
what he's doing with the fight game i
like his promoting
now he's being mr promoter jake paul
that's good for him i think he's doing
well because a lot of people didn't like
the fact that he jumped in the game and
just started to get all his attention
the fact that he did that same i was
just like i didn't know who he was
really like
but they don't understand that we boxing
needs that yes exactly he honestly
helped push
walks into his head
some of the greatest fights in that
fight and he does the boxer need a guy
like this
and also he brought into a new
demographic as well like his fans his
demographically younger differences
75 million yeah to the box office
say it again when jake paul fights he
brings 75 million people to the box
office now to the arena the box office
huh
yeah
the box office definite that's what i'm
saying like this is instagram the new
generation man he's bringing them this
is like well yeah
that's him
on a pizza
i like that jacket that's a nice jacket
he's a baller yeah man mine lives nice
after the fight so i watched him fight
nate knockout nate robinson is it nate
yeah i think so nate on that card as
well
and after i smoked we were snoop
then oh this is crazy oh [ __ ] i
don't know how bro that was
you know i did not want to see this
fight again ooh
but man if you can you can watch that
again jesus [ __ ] christ that was
he loaded that up like he charged that
up you see look at he charged that up
like he's like [ __ ] hit you bang
geez [ __ ] that was crazy that punch you
still come in a mile away that's what i
mean
he loaded that [ __ ] up he was just like
he said that [ __ ] coming a mile away
tyrone just he's five hey man by the way
he's talking a mile away yeah
no no you can see you watching he loaded
that [ __ ] up man yeah
about him fighting you or you fighting
him or logan is that something that
still
[Laughter]
levy adam i'm going straight out
how long will it take you like say right
now because you're still training actor
you're still active in just life right
now right
how long will it take you to like say
get into
fight shape
because how do you [ __ ] 45 i think
listen right yeah
dirty day the box not gonna fight
anybody 30 days 30 days yeah 30 days
diet like obviously you're gonna change
your diet all that like
30 days if i'm boxing every day in the
gym i don't have to worry about my diet
i need whatever i want
are you still vegan or did you
you're pretty much yeah yeah okay but
you're just a small amount of meat meat
okay i see i see but you look after
yourself yeah that's good yeah not easy
it's easy to see easy to see sheesh yeah
i'm still you know i'm on that seafood
diet seafood
except two weeks before the fight then i
start to like bring down my um
just the the portion sometimes or maybe
overeating because my body just knows
when it's time to cut weight like i'm
i'm amazed at what my body does when
it's like my body gets excited it's like
oh we're doing this [ __ ] now okay and
i'm like just fight week my buddy i just
have to be like relaxed listen uh that's
crazy to me that's so crazy right
because at times i'm just eating these
um
limousine lemon meringue pie oh let me
put it around
yeah
i'm keep eating these pies and stuff
mm-hmm and when it's time to stop and
stop like i never ate them before in my
life really boom you go cold turkey
whole turkey
that's interesting that yeah you so you
don't have a diet essentially until i
hop into a fight i don't like to
restrict myself like if i'm if i'm
saying during camp like seven weeks out
i'm eating as healthy as i can but if i
feel like some wendy's i'll go get some
wendy's i don't like because i've been
there before i'm like no i'm not allowed
and then eventually there's a point
there's a breaking point and then we're
not finally like
i'm one of those guys when i look in the
mirror i'm fat
ah like um body dysmorphia type thing
yeah i like to be fat yeah pig
i've honestly i've never been there but
i'm like
i understand what you mean you're
critical of yourself
yeah i feel you but hey we have to be on
i guess worst critics sometimes yeah i
am yeah that's in order to be great
anything yeah
no i'm not i need to work on this i know
sometimes like right i'm on the best
shape right now when i just fought two
weeks ago i know i've been doing work
i'm having fun but i know if i need to
get back in serious shape boom i can but
i don't hold myself to that like because
i know girls do this all the time
they're like oh
you know they just see the worst version
of themselves i'm like nah i'm not in my
best shape but i know if i need to get
in shape
like that i can get in shape easily but
yeah it takes me it takes me a while i i
do like
increments like yeah bits and pieces
yeah
it's interesting it's so interesting you
guys talking i'm the sick old guy with
the thing on my back and got the weights
behind yeah
so interesting because the fact you said
you could like cut weight like that like
so we get weighed in all the time really
so i think it's like every like maybe is
there a limit or there's so like with me
it's like a limit so mine was like 295
was the lowest i could go 295 oh what's
that in kgs what the [ __ ] 295
that's heavy you okay let me see i'm
gonna guess you are 15 grams
you uh 130 kgs yeah it's a 300 pounds
yeah wait is that 130 kgs
295 someone checked for me meanwhile let
me hit that real quick mike oh you're
beautiful yeah that's
i could just tell i i didn't that was a
math that was just looking at your body
i was like you be 130. yeah ufc coming
to africa yo that's on it has to even
dana said it what part of africa
so there's a lot of red tape in nigeria
my guy you understand i see nigeria is a
very corrupt place yeah like i love my
people but it's just the the the
government
just there as everyone's trying to find
a way to style for money from someone so
there's a lot of red tape but it can
happen in nigeria it can happen in south
africa or it can happen in morocco okay
i love south africa
you can have a problem you got brothers
this and that and it's good yeah and
then there's another game
you gotta settle everyone here
i know nigeria will be your best place
for what i feel like in nigeria like
literally if it happens and dennis said
like before he retires he wants to do a
show in the continent of africa and i
feel like it's gonna happen right now
this is history literally me
francis and kamaru what we're doing
right now we'll do the south africa yeah
so either nigeria south africa or
morocco
got the money to do yeah
from morocco that's what i'm saying like
either one of those three places can
make it happen but right now i was
talking to francis about this a week
before his last fight i said like man
where where south africa they could give
him a diamond belt and they make a new
belt for that particular fight [ __ ] they
[ __ ] the rubies put diamonds on them
like real diamonds diamonds
no in south africa in the 70s and 80s
that would build an old buck belt oh it
was about boxing yeah you know
wow
damn i'm gonna have to look that up
beautiful look better than all of our
belts
i remember that i remember that
south africa yeah oh definite from lagos
i mean from lagos yeah from lagos
i remember i took this guy as well i
took my guy jeff right there
i took him to nigeria with me
and man so i went i went to i tried to
go to the hood this this place called
makoko the slum to try and show love
back to the people
and i went there just looking to where i
look right now it's too much and i went
with one security guard like a mobile
would call them a mobile police officer
and then you know all these like
gangsters started pulling up on us like
what the [ __ ] like i'm just trying to
show love man they're like oh wait what
do you want here what do you want here
i'm like i'm just showing love man i'm
from here now so i'm gonna johnny mean
like i'm from nigeria they're like yeah
and so what like i was like oh for real
bet so my ego this is where my ego came
into play i went away that day
just like because my abiola was like we
need to go yeah i was like bad so we're
just on the outskirts and if we went
deep michael kor is like this big
floating maze on just
a shitty shitty river a shitty water
like it's really like honestly worse and
if you go deep you're in the maze you
can't get out unless someone takes you
out because they know that place like
the back of their hands
so then i went
he remembers he was there so i went back
the next day right
and then i'll put my vest on i put all
my chains on and i wore my jordans and a
puma at the time allegedly now but um
and then i um
yeah i went just flexing just like nah
and i went with like heavy security this
time yeah and then the gangsters in
there were like okay let's show you
around let's do this right right right
and jeff's got all the clips it's on my
freestyle band the youtube page as well
but then we um
yeah i i think it was just my ego to be
like look i'm from here i'm i'm coming
to show love you can't kick me out of my
own country yeah and some of the
gangsters eventually started fighting
because they wanted to like show us
around and get
and whatnot all that kind of stuff i'm
going to be seeing with you exactly also
be looked the look but then by the end
of it when i remember when it was in the
in the car it was like a zombie
apocalypse everyone had their hand out
just like trying to oh god please want
to eat someone so i'm just like white in
the window now small yeah just keeping
the money feeling like just a little bit
just a little bit but once more they got
american money yeah they did of course
yeah they like to change that's worth a
lot over there so then one smart kid who
literally just sat quietly in the car
eventually followed us out of michael
kor and then my cousin saw him was like
what the [ __ ] how'd you get in the car
and then he got out and i gave him a
little something just kind of settled
him but yeah he was a smart one because
he didn't kick off he was just like yeah
yeah obviously you know my time will
come and just like the smart game yeah
exactly so i blessed him a little bit
mm-hmm so he listened to a whiz kid then
yeah all whiskey my boy whispered the
album is nuts honestly like the one
there's one i missed the one with
blessed on it that whole album i love
steady i love blessed bro i'm like how
did i miss this album like literally i
love whiskey even davido i met davido
for the first time briefly and was it
london in london the other day yeah um
because he's gonna perform at the o2
this weekend okay and it's crazy
honestly man
afrobeat has taken over the world bro
it's so annoying loki annoys me because
it's like everyone over men everyone's
on it now like showing the love but bro
you should have been on that like now
we've been like this thing i grew up on
the street that's what i'm saying like
so for me even there was a point when i
was in the club in london and i had all
these white girls singing singing to me
in your bar
and literally i'm just like you don't
even know what you're saying but you're
singing this track to me because you
like whisked or you like you know burner
boy or whatever so i'm just like this is
crazy how afro-b has taken over and i
had this girl um
at the manchester game when i was a
football game speaking proper urobot to
me like it's crazy man like honestly i'm
just like how is that black is beautiful
yeah it is like
it's part of the culture now it's part
of the culture now so yeah guys like
whiz kid davido you know olamide burner
boy they're the ones making it happen
for the culture the show definitely yeah
their music is amazing bro yeah man that
and it's in you you feel that you just
feel it everyone feels it yeah that
means so how do you say it's not it's
legos legos so made in
that [ __ ] is nuts i suggest everyone to
go listen to that whole album it's okay
i don't skip anything you don't i don't
know i have not i did not skip one song
on that album i could still play it to
this day yeah really
this right there this is the vibe for
your name should play that [ __ ] right
now okay please play steady by whiskey
please steady by whiz kid
that's a slap all you have to do is
legit if you
have like a little gathering mic a
little barbecue party
and let that joint ride
survive i'm telling you
i'm telling you dog
if you have like date night with your
wife that's the kind of vibe you want to
play yeah
it's called duality after a hard day of
training you know wrestling sparring
with my boys all that kind of stuff i go
home i either have a bourbon
small bourbon on the rocks and i just
sit there and i can play this in the
background or smooth jazz i wish i could
drink yeah that's what boy no i could i
could die a little bit like during camp
just a little bit but yeah
yeah when i okay see things that how i
learn how to drink when i go out i go
out like it's i don't i never used to
know how to social drink yeah because
the way i grew up and i learned how to
drink that's what the culture was was
just
they even made these um like beer bongs
like that's how people drank over there
like literally just just funnel with the
hoes and
that's how they that's it it doesn't
wonder that's how they learn you know
learn how to drink and i remember yeah
so i had to learn later on in life oh
you can just have a little bit and just
catch a vibe and chill yeah as an adult
i learned that
yeah
who did that mean i met also in the uk
um derek chirosa heavyweight heavyweight
cesaro cesaro yeah i knew his face but i
was like i've seen this guy before
he's crazy so we're going to the bar in
the o2 to go drink and he goes he goes
he goes i don't drink anymore i'm like
oh well i like i like to drink he's like
do you drink heavy i'm like not once in
a while i don't drink anymore i'm like
why's that he's like i almost killed a
man i was like oh
okay
that makes sense oh well well that's fun
and then went into the o2 and i met i
met everyone i met aj i met chris eubank
jr
yeah it was just it was cool and then he
comes into the bar and just like oh this
is derek he goes what are you
[ __ ] looking at he's jerking
around like i'll smash all of you but
he's just like he's he's poking the very
poking fun but you can tell he's got a
switch in him he definitely has the
switch and he said i've been four years
sober i don't drink anymore i was like
all right bet i believe you
yeah
so definitely don't want to give him a
shot no
you don't watch tv i'll watch tape like
i said yeah i'm gonna take watch dave
watch as well yeah it's film stuff you
gotta listen i watch my opponent
the day the fight is signed
until every day until
i leave my dressing room i'm watching
them there really my dressing room like
film like you're watching my god fight
from time for me to go to my dressing
room to find a blocking the film there
watching them watching them and they
gloved me off i'm hitting them watching
them and i watch them as soon as i leave
about as long as i go out damn what's
the purpose
what did that make you feel i put me it
made me very comfortable with him oh i
see
pick up habits
i did that in my last fight um not the
same way but to get comfortable with the
arena i might like that though i might
get into that i am i did my walk out i
practiced it before i i i went out to
fight so i went there to watch my
teammates fight early on and while the
arena was empty they were setting up i
was like i want to practice my walk out
so i walked in the arena and i
visualized everything i visualized the
people the security
the fans visualize just everything the
camera crew cause their way they're
setting up as well and that made me get
comfortable so that way when i have to
go out into the arena i'm not spooked i
did it the same thing when i fought
robert the first time before i did the
dance i practiced that dance the
you're
night
before
and fighting yourself oh yeah
nervousness i like a little bit of noise
it's good fire it's good it's good it's
good it's good i wanted to be
comfortable in the arena you know what i
mean comfortable in the space so that
really helped what playing the guy's
tape actually that's that's not a bad
way to do it
you have to um
to be a good leader in anything about
gang leader what are they you have to
know how to um size people up yeah you
know how to read people facts if you
don't know how to read people you're not
a good leader mm-hmm
you know you underestimate or
overestimate somebody overestimate yeah
i like that because a lot of people
never talk about overestimating people
and i've said this as well like they
tell you never underestimate people a
lot of people overestimate people
sometimes and look at them and put them
in the bedroom they should be and then
you if this guy's off beat adventure i
was like man i was worried about you
that me too me too yeah really damn
when i was younger right i used to be an
[ __ ] and i was they say well you beat
mary holmes and
michael springs and i said some ass well
i didn't think
two great fighters with these big names
be so easy to kill oh
you know you got to talk [ __ ] about yeah
you know well you've done that once
you've done it then it's like you've
you've it's like the four-minute mile
you've done and it's like oh that was
easy
i always wanted that since i was a
little kid since i saw ali when i was in
juvenile detention i saw ali
i wanted to be like that yeah uh role
models yes big time without even trying
to be yeah without even trying to be
just being himself so he's walking to
see some bad kids and boom i want to be
like him damn
i asked when you know you've transcended
sports itself
so you both can do you both think that
bare knuckle fighting could become a
thing
there's always people out for bestiality
pastiality you gotta go to mexico for
that i heard
i've heard that is
but we always listen
let me see
there's always an audience for that cool
stuff men are always looking for a way
to show their masculinity we constantly
want to show it
we want to show our masculinity like
it's popular right now like it's they've
had a few events they have championships
they bring some big names onto their
their game but um yeah that's the nature
of people that want to show their
masculinity yeah
and then and there's always going to be
a medium for women as well yeah there's
going to be an audience for that every
single time no matter what it is like
you said listen we don't know when it
began we're never going to see it end
it's part of life fighting is part of it
yeah yeah i like the way dana puts it
about four corners if you have football
in this corner you even have hockey on
this corner you have basketball there if
a fight breaks out of that corner
everyone's going to stop yeah and then
look at the fight and people no even the
other sport guys look at the fight
exactly because we could be two oh
jewish guys fight we all stop looking at
this [ __ ] what's happening that's just
part of ours
yeah start thinking fast i don't know
these guys keep that [ __ ] them up yeah
that's true i bet on him i bet my man
right here he's gonna get up speaking of
speeding up fighting how crazy is it
that you um i don't know if you guys
heard those ukraine
boxers
they're fighting in the war yeah um even
what's the name lomachenko i saw a
picture of him that's what they should
be yeah yeah the brothers online
frontline klitschko brothers yeah
the craziest honestly out of that whole
thing one of the craziest things is the
story of the president how he was on a
sitcom or show playing the president and
then eventually that same production
company decided to run for office and
then the actor that played the president
on that show became the president of
ukraine wow he's on the front line
trying to defend the country like a true
leader and i'm just like hats off hats
off to them man that's crazy yeah
honestly one thing i do wish because i
keep seeing it everywhere is like the
way they
they need to let the um the the african
and black yeah i swear that yeah
cause a lot of nigerian students they
wouldn't let us go nowhere yeah and i've
seen the videos like one thing i've
learned mike one thing i've learned bash
is is that never react whenever [ __ ]
like this happens because george floyd
made me react
there was a speech i gave him the public
square where i was really emotional
because i mean i'm a human i see a guy
get killed by police with his hands in
his pockets i'm like what the [ __ ] is
that but then now i've learned never
react respond so even though i'm
speaking this is my first time speaking
on this kind of stuff now the ukraine
situation in russia and what nigerian
students are going through there it's
like i don't like to react i like to
respond so i'll wait and see first and
i've seen some i've been i've just seen
too many videos and too many incidents
where like you see nigerian students
being denied game denied and you see
like you know a white lady just jump
over the fence put their baby over the
train yeah that's like it's crazy and
then you see people even getting guns
pulled on them they're like look we're
just students we just want to let which
one and that's like yo
some of the leaders though from where
i'm from that's why i'm talking about
where i'm saying like they're corrupt
and there's a lot of red tape they need
to take action and be like look let's
send planes over for nigerian citizens
only and get them back home
if the the you know the polish or the
other neighboring countries won't let
them in mm-hmm because what's going to
happen you're going to leave them in the
like sitting ducks
yeah it's crazy i was like i don't know
what i'm not a politician so i don't
know what sparked that whole situation
i'm learning bits and pieces of it
there's a black girl who kind of speaks
about it in ebonics on on tick tock or
instagram and i follow her page i can't
remember her name now but then i kind of
get the gist of it but i'm not gonna i'm
not a political expert but [ __ ]
it's just sad
it's sad when you see it you see babies
in the who's supposed to be in the
hospital six day old babies in the in in
a warehouse being looked after that's
like man
yeah [ __ ]
well i'm sorry to bring it to this slice
so let's make it positive and on a
positive note
so
before we go before what are you what
are you thankful for who you all want to
shout out
what are you thankful for what do you
feel blessed about who you want to shout
out real quick good vibes only yeah good
vibes okay good vibes honestly right now
i'm blessed with with the people i have
around me
the people i have around me that's one
thing i've i've come to learn lately
especially the end of last year um
like
people came and left my life dropped
some dead weight but oh people have a
yeah
honestly
it frees you yeah i'm telling you you
never realize it's like you can't see
the force for the trees you never
realize till it's gone and you're like
damn yeah you don't realize you're
freezing it was holding me back i was
not i was always free but thing is i
never realized it's like rock lee in
naruto when he took the weights off
legs exactly
fast i feel that's where i'm at right
now i'm going to say where all this
money comes from
same even i got a new deal all these
other things are happening that's really
positive in my life i'm like man i'm
just happy with the people i have around
me because you ever think about putting
this guy on screen me later on after
fighting after fighting real though
right now
i'm focused i'm focused after fighting a
little bit no i i like it that's that's
the boy got four blunts in his hand
casually
it's back home but um yeah so it's just
i'm just happy to have the people i have
around me because yeah they they really
care about me and they really want
what's best for me for sure you know
one thing i
like
before even my parents believed in my
dream they still supported me yeah and
i've had people or someone telling me
like you know your family's only around
you for your money i'm like
where the [ __ ] were you when i had no
money my family being there from the
[ __ ] get-go i don't give your family
no money and give it to me
no that's what that's what you're trying
to say well i'm saying like nah they've
been there the whole time when i had no
money when they didn't even my mom and
dad didn't believe in what i was gonna
do because no one from my country had
done it yet so they're like they still
supported me whenever i had no money
whenever i'm like yo pups can you loan
me a hundred bucks they'll they'll
support me now bless them they deserve
everything even even before fighting
just like being their son growing up the
way we did
you know trying to get a better life
from for us by moving to the western
world
i bless them now and the people around
me as well i make sure
i don't like to i don't like to like
give fishes i like to like teach them
how to fish you know because even my
pups are teaching me how to fish they'll
say give a man a fish or eat for a day
give him teach him how to fish and eat
for a lifetime so bible people with me
my brother he's my producer for my
freestyle bender youtube page he started
that whole [ __ ] up and now he's to be
some big time producer somewhere because
he can do whatever he wants yes sir
security guard he's already like running
madison square garden he's about to run
for yes sir what's the name crypto.com
center tomorrow night when we go watch
the game you know like i put people in
positions for me so they can like teach
themselves how to fish or feed for
themselves because i don't need no
leeches around me or no yes men you know
so yeah i just i'm just grateful for the
people i have around me and [ __ ] like i
said about the joe rogan situation [ __ ]
the noise just focus on the people
around you and focus on love because
everyone forgets man it just feels good
to do good for other people amen
everyone always forgets and trust me
it's selfish but at least you're doing
good for someone else and you never do
it for likes you do it for love
amen amen preach well there you have i
get a witness
that's the holy ghost real quick but
there you have it that is mike tyson i'm
sebastian joseph day super bowl champ
yeah you heard that yes yeah talk your
[ __ ]
talk your [ __ ] we outside and
you will never forget us i know you
heard that easy we out here zak hop
boxing we outside
later
you